>>> THIS MORNING OFFICIA IN
KYIV SAY THE UKRAINIAN ENERGY
AGENCY WILL PUT IN PLACE SEVERE,
CUTS IN EFFORTS TO AVOID A ER
COMPLETE BLACKOUT.
THAT MOVE COMING AFTER RUSSIAN
STRIKES ON UKRAINIAN ENERGY
FACILITIES OVERNIGHT.
JOINING ME CNN INTERNATIONAL
DIPLOMATIC EDITOR NIC ROBERTSON
WHO HAD EXCLUSIVE ACCESS TO THE
POWER STATION DESTROYED BY
RUSSIA.
NIC, WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT
THIS.
WE'VE YET TO SEE THE PICTURES.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING ON THE
GROUND?
>> Reporter: IT'S QUITE
STAGGERING.
IN ONE WAY, MUCH OF THE BUILDING
HERE ISN'T DAMAGED OR DESTROYED.
WHAT'S UNCANNY OR EERIE, IT'S
SILENT.
WHAT THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO IS TARGET SOME
OF THE MOST SENSITIVE EQUIPMENT.
POWER STATIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HERE HAVE BECOME THE
TARGET OVER THE PAST COUPLE
WEEKS FOR THE RUSSIAN MISSILES,
FOR THE RUSSIAN DRONES.
INDEED, JUST AS WE ARRIVED HERE,
THE SIRENS WERE GOING OFF.
WE IMMEDIATELY WENT INTO THE
BUNKER WHERE A LOT OF THE OTHER
WORKERS FROM HERE, DOZENS OF
PEOPLE IN AN UNDERGROUND BUNKER.
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF NORMAL
HERE.
I WAS SPEAKING TO ONE OF THE
WORKERS.
HE SAID, LOOK, WE'RE GETTING
USED TO THIS.
WE SPEND HOURS EVERY DAY STUCK
DOWN HERE.
THEY'VE GOT INTERNET DOWN THERE.
THEY CAN MESSAGE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES.
ONE GUY WAS PLAYING CHESS ON HIS
PHONE.
SO THEY'RE NOW COWED BY THE
MISSILES THAT ARE COMING, BUT
IT'S PREVENTING THEM FROM DOING
THE MUCH-NEEDED REPAIRS.
WHEN WE GOT OUT, WE COULD SEE
BUILDINGS BLOWN APART, DRONE AND
CRUISE MISSILES HIT HERE.
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUT UP SOME
OF THE PYLONS THAT HAVE BEEN
KNOCKED DOWN, REPAIR SOME OF THE
BUILDING WORK.
BUT THERE'S CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE THAT IS
REALLY HARD TO REPLACE, PARTLY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MANUFACTURED
ANYMORE.
THESE PLANTS ARE VERY OLD.
SO IT'S HARD TO GET.
THEY'RE LOOKING AROUND THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY TO TRY TO FIND
REPLACEMENT SPARE PARTS, LOOKING
TO INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS TO
FIND THE SPARE PARTS.
YOU LOOK AROUND THE PARTS OF
THIS POWER STATION THAT HAVE
BEEN HIT, THERE ARE BURNT
CABLES, BURNT TRANSFORMERS.
THERE'S EQUIPMENT ROOMS RIPPED
OPEN.
LOTS OF PEOPLE TRYING TO REPAIR
IT.
AS I SAY, THEY'RE FORCED A LOT
OF THE TIME OF THE DAY TO SPEND
IT IN BUNKERS BECAUSE OF THE AIR
RAID SIRENS.
>> ALSO, AS YOU POINT OUT, SOME
OF THOSE OUTDATED PIECES AND THE
CONCERN OF THESE ON GOING
STRIKES.
WHAT'S THE ASSESSMENT IN TERMS
OF DEALING WITH ALL OF THAT TO
GET THE REPAIRS DONE IN ADVANCE
OF POTENTIALLY MORE STRIKES?
>> Reporter: THAT'S THE REAL
TEST FOR THE GOVERNMENT AT THE
MOMENT.
30 TO 40% OF THE POWER NETWORK
IN THE COUNTRY DOWN.
THE TEST IS QUITE SIMPLY THIS,
CAN THEY REPAIR FASTER THAN
RUSSIA IS DESTROYING?
YES, YOU CAN REPAIR THE POWER
LINES.
YOU CAN PUT UP NEW CONCRETE
PILLARS, BUILD NEW ROOFS, YOU
CAN COVER THE WINDOWS.
SOME OF THE COMPLEX ITEMS THAT
ARE BEING DESTROYED, THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE POTENTIALLY
MONTHS.
INDEED, I'VE ASKED A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE HERE HOW LONG WILL IT
TAKE YOU TO REPAIR THIS.
THEY CAN'T PUT A DATE ON IT
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T KNOW
WHEN THEY CAN GET THE PARTS.
EVERY DAY MORE OF THE SYSTEM,
MORE OF THE PARTS GET TAKEN
DOWN.
IMAGINE THIS, ALL THIS DAMAGE,
30 TO 40% IS IN THE PAST TWO
WEEKS.
THEY KNOW HERE, THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE CAN BE WEEKS MORE OF
THIS.
THEY KNOW THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
IS WORKING WITH RUSSIAN
ELECTRICAL ENGINEERS TO TARGET
THE MOST SENSITIVE PLACES AND
DAMAGE THE MOST HARD-TO-REPLACE
EQUIPMENT AT THESE SITES.
IT IS A VULNERABILITY.
PUTIN KNOWS IT.
EVERYONE I'VE TALKED TO AT THIS
PLANT HERE, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THEM, JUST WANT TO DO THE BEST
REPAIR JOB THEY CAN, BUT THEY
KNOW IT'S A HUGE UPHILL BATTLE.
>> IT REALLY IS.
NIC, GREAT ACCESS AND SO GREAT
TO HAVE THAT COLOR FROM YOU AS
WELL OF WHAT IT IS REALLY LIKE
FOR THESE CREWS, FOR THE FOLKS
ON THE GROUND.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.